do y'all know chyy Von okay never mind
maybe I should do a different one some
of some of
this and then it's some of this and then
that okay it was okay on a scale of 1 to
10 I'd give it a like a dad joke it's so
bad that it's
good thank you how many followers do you
have on Instagram I have like
950 ooh that's low the lowest out of all
yeah so what's your best pickup liner
like riss in general I look him look him
in the eyes and I say I like your
smile and that's pretty much it you
still live with your parents why should
we think you're cool I I see good in
people I do cool stuff I used to be a
therapist I have a very good family
friend who's a play therapist yeah maybe
I know her you probably don't oh okay
what do you do during your free time
some times I cut my hair um yourself
yeah actually a little bit what are the
stories behind your tattoo well this is
a betta fish oh I have a betta fish oh
really three two
one oh my God thanks guys you're all
really cool thank you thank you wow
we're rating everybody really high we
need to give more of these people lows
let's stop sugar coating them